main thing is the plot and the
characters are very compelling so I
think it really sort of captures people
is there's a because there's so many
different storylines going on there's so
many amazing character hi dad and and
yeah there's loads of yeah those are
amazing stuff you know and you kind of
really get it's really getting absorbed
by the characters and get involved in
them and you know you really don't want
them to die but inevitably they always
do it's quite good fun yeah and I think
with ramsey because he's so happy and he
really enjoys doing what he's doing he
gets incredible joy of being horrible so
it's kind of it's kind of in a way you
kind of injury leave feeling quite
elated by role which is really dark
there are things obviously I feel oh my
god that's terrible but yeah he's just
yeah it's easier than putting a very
weighty character that is everything
inside Lisa just lets everything out in
a cathartic manner
yeah it's written oh and it's cool you
know actors kind of my agent I might
have known for we all sort of hang out
or whatever beep beep it Harrington
Alfie Allen the pool as much as I can
and yeah it's great that was really good
good bunch of people